[Música]
en primera plana y bienvenidos en
primera plana un programa de radio
france internacional de france 24 esta
semana ponemos el foco en perú un país
que atraviesa una gran crisis política
de grandes dimensiones para ello nos
acompañan en este estudio y paso ya
saludar al isr quirós historiadora
profesora de estudios latinoamericanos
en la universidad sergi de parís
bienvenida al isr gracias por límites mi
compañera anahí rivadeneira periodista
aquí en radio francia internacional
bienvenida a danae hola carlos y en
dúplex desde lima el politólogo gustavo
pastor señor pastor buenos días
espero un país ingobernable hoy nos lo
planteamos aquí en primera plana
[Música]
la destitución por el congreso de perú
del presidente martín vizcarra
investigado por recibir supuestos pagos
irregulares representa otra grave
sacudida en el panorama político del
país andino en el que todos los jefes de
estado desde 1985 han terminado siendo
investigados o procesados por delitos de
corrupción está la institución y la
investigación de la fiscalía vuelve a
poner sobre la mesa la asignatura
pendiente de la democracia peruana que
es la lucha contra la corrupción sin ir
más lejos varios de los impulsores de la
institución están encausados detenidos o
bajo arresto domiciliario por delitos
como lavado de dinero o financiación
ilegal el clima de desconfianza de los
peruanos hacia sus políticos puede
determinar las elecciones presidenciales
de abril de 2021 hoy en en primera plana
vamos a buscar más allá de la coyuntura
donde están las raíces de esta
problemática en perú seguramente algunas
de ellas son extrapolables a otros
países de su entorno antes repasemos
algunas portadas la republica el perú
dice no al golpe se refiere a las
multitudinarias marchas contra la
destitución de martín vizcarra ya saben
que el conservador manuel merino lo
sustituyó antes de
acabar también dimitiendo y ahora de
forma interina está en el cargo
francisco sagasti una figura que en
principio ofrece mayor consenso pero eso
ahora sólo voy a preguntar a nuestros
invitados pero 21 dos muertos en las
protestas inaceptable las protestas
contra el presidente interino ya ha
dimitido manuel merino el comercio
califica precisamente al nuevo ejecutivo
de transición como de alto perfil
técnico y con experiencia de estado pero
la crisis de hoy que vive perú no es
algo puntual de ahora sino que se ha ido
sedimentando por décadas podríamos decir
no lissl como podríamos explicar las
raíces profundas de esta crisis que va
más allá de la coyuntura puntual pienso
que ante todo hay una demanda de los
peruanos y las peruanas de una
democracia para asentar verdaderamente
la democracia peruana se puede decir que
hay tres causas sobre otras puntos
primero el perú desde su formación en el
siglo 19 no tomó en cuenta a todos a
todas las peruanas ya todos los peruanos
no sea la constitución fue hecha un poco
para un grupo
de la élite y no ha ido cambiando con el
tiempo muy progresivamente los los y las
indígenas votan en perú a partir
solamente de 1978 luego tenemos también
que el estado no se ha mostrado siempre
incapaz de poder romper este círculo
vicioso y no integrar o no hacer que
todas y todos los peruanos participen
verdaderamente y sean sobre todo tengan
condiciones dignas de vida y todo esto
es lo que hoy día hemos visto en estas
marchas una demanda global por un cambio
estructural de la política peruana esta
crisis se produce en un contexto
especial a pocos meses de las elecciones
en perú en un contexto de pandemia
además con la crisis económica es decir
la inestabilidad siempre ha estado ahí
pero a lo mejor este contexto refuerza
la peligrosidad de esta inestabilidad en
este momento justo sí es verdad es
verdad que la crisis de la pandemia del
nuevo coronavirus ha jugado un rol pero
sobre todo creo que ha desnudado cosas
que estaban allí pero que la gente creía
que no estábamos antes se creía que
perú gozaba de una estabilidad económica
que estaba muy bien que había cada vez
menos desigualdad pero lo cierto es que
con la pandemia llega y uno se da cuenta
de las diferencias enormes entre las
clases que habían se da cuenta que la
gente que podía acceder a la salud era
solamente la gente que pagaba entonces
todo ese tipo de cosas empiezan a
desnudarse y algo que es interesante y
sintomático es que justamente uno de los
por decir los logros de fujimori yo lo
digo logros de manera sarcástica era
hacer creer que había que pasar
necesariamente por lo privado y decir
que el estado en realidad se metiera lo
menos posible no entonces justamente con
la llegada de la pandemia
la gente se fue dando cuenta de que lo
que había creído no era tan cierto y en
encuestas la gente pedía y decía que
creía que el estado tenía que tener un
rol mucho más activo en eso no que las
empresas no podían entrar y manejar todo
como si todo fuera un negocio entonces y
eso nos lleva yo creo que bueno vamos a
conversar seguramente va a ser el tema
de la corrupción y como como es que el
tema económico se ha metido en
absolutamente todo el tema económico
corrupto
vamos a esta lima con nuestro politólogo
gustavo desde que comenzó el siglo xiv
bien hecho las cuentas pero ha elegido a
cinco presidentes por el voto popular
todos ellos han sido condenados o
enfrentan procesos en la justicia donde
hay que buscar las causas de esta
inestabilidad política en perú que al
menos desde fuera sorprende de mucho
y dijo si tenemos algún problema para
escuchar a gustavo vamos a ver si
podemos mejorar esa esa conexión de
michelle y hablemos de cómo hemos
llegado a la situación actual porque se
investiga el destituído martín vizcarra
vizcarra está como los demás políticos
podríamos decir hay una serie de casos
de corrupción donde se ha visto sobre
todo en su gestión el fue gobernador de
la región una región del sur del perú
que es moquegua y entonces ha habido se
han descubierto que habían varias casos
donde él está implicado y tiene donde ha
recibido nos coimas como nos decimos
nosotros en perú y además contratos que
no están muy claros ilícitos por ejemplo
con un cantante que ha contratado por la
presidencia o sea durante también la
presidencia entonces todo esto ha ido
a estos estos casos durante gracias a la
prensa en particular que los ha revelado
y eso ha generado la investigación que
se abriera una investigación contra el
que es decir una investigación para
aclarar esta esta situación y en eso ha
estado pero todavía no ha llegado a
término y no tenemos un proceso y es un
poco lo que ha parecido a la opinión
pública peruana particular es decir que
todos como lo ha señalado los
presidentes los políticos los
congresistas tienen estas
investigaciones y al único que se ha
destituido o al que se distribuye en
estas circunstancias está martín
vizcarra y no se entiende bien entonces
porque va hacia él
estas investigaciones durante su mandato
no es no luego y todo esto ha generado
una
en gran preocupación pero creo que es la
gran preocupación de los peruanos y las
peruanas no es decir como gobernar la
gobernabilidad del país esta es un país
inestable un país que ha sido que se
enfrenta a una crisis de la salud
sumamente importante el perú es el
segundo país más afectado por la la coi
de 19 a todo esto ha generado una gran
preocupación que ha movilizado a todos
estos peruanos durante durante varios
días
danae consideramos la moderación de
martín vizcarra podría permitir esa
transición de sagasti es efectivamente
de sagasti pues digamos el obtenido es
cierto que ha obtenido mucho mayor
consenso actualmente porque claro la
persona que había sido puesta antes en
la que estaba como presidenta del
congreso de momentáneamente no obtuvo el
consenso si puede puede que sí puede que
obtenga el consenso él es una persona
moderada de centro o centroderecha pero
yo quiero llamar justamente aquí la
atención que la moderación no es siempre
algo bueno digamos
porque por ejemplo se haga si entro él
dentro después de estas masivas
manifestaciones acabaron con la muerte
de estos dos chicos con 40 personas
desaparecidas con más de 100 detenciones
arbitrarias con denuncias de vejaciones
sexuales pues durante esas semanas
durante la semana de merino fue como una
semana de autoritarismo que el perú
vivió y que no vivía desde antes de éste
fujimori digamos entonces lo que hubiese
correspondido es que sagasti ni bien
entrará si bien él pidió perdón a las
familias y tal que él deslindará con los
mandos policiales ni bien entrará no y
él lo que dijo fue bueno hay
responsabilidades de malos elementos
recién a los pocos días él se decidió y
dijo vamos a cambiar la cúpula de la
policía vamos a sacar a todos los
generales y lo hizo no pero entonces yo
llamo la atención acerca de este intento
primero por poner las aguas tibias y por
no de repente preocupar a la gente que
apoya a la policía puede tal vez al
final resultar contradictorio no
entonces no siempre el hecho de que sea
moderado quiere decir que vaya a ser
bueno estábamos hablando antes con liz
el de martín vizcarra
de las cuotas de popularidad que llegó a
tener tengo aquí no todos 79% llegó a
rozar durante la pandemia es decir si
era un presidente tenía gozaba de un
gran apoyo popular una gran aprobación
como lo dices 80 prácticamente 80 por
ciento en abril y mayo de este año y
creo que se debe a diversos factores
principales que se presentó como un
hombre que estaba luchando
verdaderamente contra la corrupción no
se hubo todo un proceso desde ya de
apelación al putt
al pueblo lanzando un referendo luego
enfrentándose al congreso y también al
poder judicial que son los poderes que
estaban políticos que estaban habían
sido que había visto la cómo estaban
corruptos estructuralmente entonces él
lanzó una serie de reformas la reforma
del congreso para que no hayan
reelección es de congresistas para
limitar también el financiamiento de los
partidos políticos toda una reforma
judicial
entonces todo esto le da una una imagen
buena sin contar que durante la pandemia
el perú fue el primer país en confirmar
a la población casi prácticamente al
mismo tiempo que francia por ejemplo y
con un confinamiento uno de los más
estrictos del mundo entonces todo esto
le da una imagen de un hombre
responsable que estaba actuando y
actuando para limitar los problemas que
el pueblo reclamaba en todo caso lo
contra los cuales estaba movilizado
entonces allí esta imagen es un hombre
también un hombre que sale de no de la
del ambiente político tradicional del
perú es un nombre de las regiones que
una región sur entonces todo esto le da
como una credibilidad importante en el
público vamos a hacer aquí una breve
pausa en unos instantes les quiero
preguntar eh lóriz por el horizonte de
las elecciones del año que viene que se
abre en perú está de esta crisis
política vamos a ver si podemos con
conectar con lima con nuestro politólogo
pero va a ser a vuelta de la pausa
[Música]
es claro que la época navideña este año
alemania va a ser distinta va a ser
extraña distinta porque la mayoría de
los mercadillos de navidad esa tradición
tan importante para los alemanes en esta
época del año han sido cancelados para
evitar aglomeraciones masivas distintas
porque la vida pública ha sido reducida
drásticamente en muy pocos eventos
culturales y los bares los restaurantes
y los museos continúan cerrados distinta
porque hay límites en cuanto al número
de personas que pueden hacer compras al
tiempo en los almacenes que permanecen
abiertos distinta porque una de las
grandes tradiciones de año nuevo en este
país esas celebraciones masivas en las
calles con fuegos artificiales también
han sido cancelados esto no significa
sin embargo que los alemanes no vayan a
poder celebrar la navidad el gobierno
estimó y decidió que máximo diez
personas excluyendo a los niños podrán
reunirse entre el 23 de diciembre y el
1º de enero a celebrar la navidad de esa
manera las autoridades por un lado
esperan que las restricciones ayuden a
reducirlos
los casos de coronavirus y por el otro
lado igual se pueda garantizar que los
alemanes celebren la navidad en familia
[Música]
los británicos tendrán un respiro de 5
días del 23 al 27 de diciembre ya que el
gobierno autorizó reunirse entre un
máximo de 3 hogares y formar una burbuja
social para celebrar estas fiestas
navideñas
además levantará las restricciones de
viaje en el reino unido- para que las
personas puedan desplazarse y reunirse
brevemente con sus seres queridos eso sí
los abrazos y los besos a los abuelos no
están recomendados por el riesgo de
contagio las tiendas le abrirán sus
puertas después de este segundo
confinamiento nacional a partir del
próximo 3 de diciembre a tiempo para las
compras navideñas también los
restaurantes y los tradicionales pops
ingleses podrán recibir gente a partir
de la próxima semana con restricciones y
con distanciamiento social y es que el
reino unido- ha sido el país más
golpeado por la pandemia en europa con
más de 57 mil muertes oficiales
[Música]
uno de los mayores acontecimientos
navideños en españa' es el sorteo
extraordinario de lotería de navidad que
se celebra el 22 de diciembre y en el
que se calcula que participa la mitad de
la población con un gasto medio por
español de unos 70 euros y los españoles
compran directamente aquí en las
oficinas de loterías y apuestas del
estado pero también en el trabajo en
clubes deportivos o en bares y
restaurantes sus participaciones un
último depósito de la esperanza para
mejorar la situación económica sobre
todo en estos tiempos de crisis y para
paliar esta crisis autoridades como la
alcaldesa de barcelona ha pedido a la
población que realice las compras
navideñas también en locales de
proximidad y por lo que hace a la
vertiente más social y familiar de estas
fiestas falta que el gobierno acuerde
con las autonomías su propuesta que de
momento limita las reuniones a un máximo
de seis personas y permite que en
nochebuena y en nochevieja se retrase el
toque de queda hasta la una de la
madrugada
[Música]
me muerdo los labios para no llamarte me
queman tus besos
con daños sentimientos directores en
cantantes bailarines y otros personajes
de la cultura nos hablan sin rodeos
sobre sus carreras y vivencias
personales lo que nos acerca aún más a
su público sólo una banda que también
somos aburguesados
crisis que atraviesa perú la crisis
política con el historiador alice el
quirós la periodista danae rivadeneira y
en dúplex desde lima el politólogo
gustavo pastor bueno estábamos hablando
de la popularidad antes de la pausa él
es el que tiene martín vizcarra que
tenia martín vizcarra que llegó a cuotas
de casi el 80 por ciento durante la
pandemia no sí sí o casi 80% de una
población una aprobación muy importante
para un presidente y que se debía que
sea debido a esta lucha que ha tenido
contra la corrupción en todo caso que la
presentaba así a la vez contra el
congreso contra el poder judicial
también todos esos políticos que están
envueltos en procedimientos contra de
corrupción y también su gestión de la
pandemia que ha sido aprobada
aquí tal vez es necesario matizar porque
si bien él tenía bastante popularidad y
aceptación él tuvo varias medidas
consideradas populistas de hecho es una
de las ventajas es que le escuchas y
bastante pero es cierto que todo eso se
enmarca también en jugadas políticas en
cosas que le convienen entonces al
inicio él por ejemplo cuando él era tú
cuándo kuczynski el presidente que tuvo
que renunciar por el proceso de
corrupción él se sabe que ha habido
conversaciones con la bancada
fujimorista no entonces digamos que las
acciones de vizcarra se enmarcan si en
oponerse a un congreso pero una gente
que se oponía a ellos ya digamos detrás
de él habían intereses políticos
personales y particulares entonces es
por eso que algunas personas dicen que
finalmente bueno
analistas no dicen que él es el traidor
que ha sido traicionado luego no creo
que al final se le revirtió en el plato
lo que él había hecho al inicio el
traidor tradicional no sé si tendremos
de alguna conexión con lima con nuestro
puerto luego gustavo pastor gustavo
donde hay que buscar las causas de esta
inestabilidad política que vive perú con
con tantos presidentes sin condenados o
enfrentados a procesos con la justicia
yo creo que hay que buscar en dos
lugares uno que es la línea de
estabilidad se llama la confrontación
entre el parlamento y el ejecutivo no
eso digamos desde el 2016 hasta ahora ha
hecho que prácticamente todas las
personas que estaban digamos dentro del
juego político de 2016 y aquí estamos
pero por lo muchísimo esta periodista no
está la segunda vicepresidenta no está
el simbolismo tampoco nadie pero pues
digamos que es un sistema que fue muy
destructivo y nos dio esta situación y
la otra cosa que yo veo es el escándalo
de break porque no siempre había habido
corrupción desde 2015 por ejemplo es
toledo ollanta y alan garcía tenían
investigaciones pero cuando llegaba al
poder que llega la confirmación de dónde
venía la plata y eso ha ido llevando que
todos pues vayan a crear investigaciones
algunos
han estado detenido preliminarmente y
presidente alan garcía de suicidio
cuando vieron a detener
si yo puedo agregar que luego también es
importante
ir a cómo funcionan los partidos
políticos que actualmente funcionan más
como una empresa que como un lugar donde
hay de verdad de compromisos y biología
entonces funciona más como el que es el
dueño de la marca por decirlo así o el
dueño del partido le recibe aportes y
según ellos se decide como quien va a
tener el primer número el segundo número
el tercer número en la lista congresal
no entonces es un problema grave porque
al final no hay legitimidad no hay no
hay lealtad no hay lealtad es esa es la
palabra no hay lealtades entre ellos
sino todo es más bien una cuestión
económica no dice él
que hemos cambiado también de época y
hoy día los latinoamericanos en general
y los peruanos en particular ya no
aceptan funcionamientos que antes se
podía tolerar creo que también hay un
cambio de mentalidad y está eso es
positivo es decir que ahora reclamar a
los políticos una honestidad que
y una transparencia que no existido
tradicionalmente que no teníamos
tradicionalmente y que ahora ya es una
exigencia
y me parece lógica y importante que
diseña la reforma constitucional y nueva
constitución eran las frases que podían
leerse en las movilizaciones celebradas
estos días en lima para pedir justicia
por la muerte de dos jóvenes recordemos
muerte de dos jóvenes manifestantes
durante la violenta represión de las
protestas contra el gobierno interino de
manuel merino
hace ya más de una semana desde luego
cuando un alguien en ese cargo tiene que
utilizar la represión de esa forma
contra su propio pueblo ya es un síntoma
no desde algo
si se ha abierto con esta crisis un
debate y le pregunto gustavo sobre una
reforma constitucional en el país
y fijaría todo digamos un debate ahora
yo no sé hasta qué punto va a llegar a
que haya una verdadera reforma porque
probablemente que ahorita hay un
gobierno transitorio de 8 meses tendría
que ser el próximo gobierno y no es
seguro en las personas esté en el
próximo parlamento pues ya mejor es que
está y que puedan digamos reformarlo y
hacer todas las reformas que la
población pide además los grupos que
están pidiendo esto tomás ligado digamos
a jóvenes y en la grupo de izquierda y
pues bien la elección de sagarpa ya
vimos que la izquierda a pesar de que
tiene mucha escucha mucho pues ante esa
característica vuestra por una señora
rocío silva santisteban y no le dieron
digamos la presidencia el congreso
porque era de izquierda entonces todavía
con este parlamento es un poco difícil
que se va a poder hacer en este caso de
constitución pero no se sabe
posiblemente en el próximo gobierno que
es un tema que entre con fuerza y para
las elecciones también veamos pegado que
tengan cambio constitución
como comodato antes del llamado golpe de
merino ya había una encuesta que decía
que el 56 por ciento de los peruanos
estaba a favor de un cambio
constitucional antes a entonces después
de esto después de lo que ha pasado de
merino y sobre todo hace unos días hubo
algo importante es que vizcarra había
pedido el tribunal constitucional que se
manifestara si es que la vacancia contra
él había sido bien hecha o no el
tribunal tenía que decir sí sí o no al
final decidieron la mayoría de miembros
lavarse las manos y no hacer nada esto
quiere decir que se deja la puerta
abierta para que en un nuevo congreso
para que actualmente vuelva a pasar lo
mismo o sea para que se vuelva a bajar
yo creo que esto de aquí es un motivo
más para que la gente pueda pedir y se
relanza el tema del cambio
constitucional creo que es una reforma
muy simbólica y se puede poner en
paralelo con el caso chileno porque
justamente son dos países
que van y que funcionan o sea que todo
caso que tiene mucha conexión la
constitución que tenemos es la
constitución que fue votada en 1993
durante el gobierno de fujimori y con lo
que sabemos que es un gobierno
autoritario y entonces exacto y entonces
ahí esta demanda que es a través de la
constitución transformar en profundidad
el sistema político entonces creo que es
un poco la es una medida simbólica que
vamos a ver cómo se puede poner en
práctica porque lo cambiar la
constitución creo que muchas personas
pueden estar de acuerdo ahora cómo se
hace una constitución que de verdad sea
inclusiva que pueda responder a todos
los sectores de la población eso es algo
que tanto en chile como en perú va a ser
complicado llevar a cabo llegados a este
punto y explicada a las raíces les
pregunto por el horizonte vamos a ver
qué hay en el horizonte se podrá llegar
en calma hasta las elecciones de abril
que esperan de esta cita electoral de
2021 gustavo cómo se presenta esta cita
electoral de 2021
bueno está bastante mal no porque
digamos los mismos problemas de 2016
presentes en el 2021 los dos candidatos
que se presentan son prácticamente los
mismos que en este disco estamos más
tarde
acuña con los mismos personajes y para
las elecciones en el parlamento también
no hay ninguna garantía de que con estas
reglas vuelva entre personas que se
parezcan mucho las que están actualmente
teníamos populistas y que tomas
decisiones a veces contra los intereses
detalles muchas veces no que son los que
han provocado esta crisis entonces
realmente es difícil que las cosas
mejoren siempre pueden haber sorpresas y
esto tiene mucho que ver también con el
nivel de educación del país porque
digamos los parlamentarios también de
todas las regiones del país lleguen al
parlamento
y simplemente con educación
el elecciones 2021 una oportunidad para
el país o va a seguir todo más o menos
de la misma forma el problema es que
tenemos poco tiempo y como lo hemos
dicho es un partido tenemos partidos
políticos que son partidos que se crean
se gestan prácticamente para los
comicios y que desaparecen
inmediatamente después que se salen
elegidos las personas no hay una base en
realidad de política de estructura
partidaria sólida y eso es un gran
problema para estas elecciones sin
contar que seguimos en crisis sanitaria
y vamos a ver cómo se puede organizar
también comicios que son obligatorios en
perú para toda la población en buenas
condiciones
todo esto nos deja mucha expectativa y
interrogantes que espero de verdad como
peruana que se puedan desde ya dar en
compass con tranquilidad y que se puedan
realizar
sin fraude por ejemplo antes gustaba lo
tocaba de forma tangencial
es menos importante que la destitución
de vizcarra apunte nuevamente a la que
es probablemente la mayor trama de
corrupción internacional en sudamérica
con ramificaciones en otros continentes
incluso como es el caso odebrecht que ha
provocado por ejemplo un terremoto
institucional en brasil ha destapado
algunas cloacas en mexico esta crisis
ante todo demuestra que la corrupción
como ocurre con el virus no conoce
fronteras es decir lo que perú ha sido
especialmente tocado por a pero
totalmente claro todos los presidentes
solo decías al inicios del 85 está acá
todos están tienen acusaciones de
corrupción investigaciones algunos están
en la cárcel otro se suicidó para para
no ir a la cárcel por el tema de
corrupción entonces sí claro la
corrupción es un mal es un mal endémico
y el problema además que no solamente la
clase política sino es que también los
grandes empresarios los empresarios
fuertes también están metidos en esta
historia de corrupción entonces tienes
economía y política corruptas unidas
haces un engranaje que no acaba nunca y
como como decía gustavo al final todo
eso se condensó en el tema odebret
trabajado porque se vio que desde la
izquierda hasta la derecha todos
han sido pagados hayan recibido algún
tipo de beneficio de coima de entonces
evidentemente claro el problema endémico
de nuestro país es la corrupción
gustavo algún último apunte
no quiero apuntar de que digamos de las
razones que a mí me parece que por las
que usted gran movilización es tal vez
tiene que ver con que discar un político
muy astuto que la había sabido crear una
narrativa entre digamos los malos y los
buenos el presentado como el digamos el
campeón de la lucha contra la corrupción
y luego pues que haya todos estos
manejos y la gente se dé cuenta de que
están bien formado parte de esta trama
que supuestamente el extranjero yo creo
que creó una de las indignación que ha
hecho que la gente sale a las calles a
protestar un poco digamos desorientados
porque claro prácticamente todos están
no se esperaba que no esté dentro de los
recientes productos y también forma
parte de esta galería
pues muchísimas gracias gustavo pastor
desde el imán muchísimas gracias también
a liz el quirós ya mi compañera dará
rivadeneira nos ustedes he aprendido un
montón sobre perú y esta crisis de la
que tanto estamos hablando estos días en
los informativos de todo el mundo esta
crisis que asola el perú estaremos
pendientes de esa perspectiva de las
elecciones en 2021 muchísimas gracias
y a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana aquí en primera plana de r&d
france24